hey it's peter here with the gs news
update today during their nintendo
direct nintendo announced a lot of great
new things and we've got the top three
announcements right here for you let's
get it out of the way majora's mask is
confirmed for the 3ds with updated
graphics just like the ocarina of time
3ds version you can finally bring one of
the best zelda games ever made with you
wherever you go no word yet on if there
will be any new features added to the
game such as the master's quest which
was added to the ocarina of time 3ds
update currently the majora's mask
remake is slated for release in spring
2015. also shigeru miyamoto created
three pikmin short animations this year
for the tokyo international film
festival and those 20-minute shows are
now available to purchase as a package
with five dollars you can pick them up
in 3d to watch on the 3ds or an hd to
watch on the wii u but annoyingly you
have to purchase them twice if you want
to watch on both platforms there's also
a new demo for pikmin 3 available on the
nintendo eshop in case you don't have
the game and want to check it out
the other cool thing that caught our eye
is the latest addition to the virtual
console duck hunt the original game will
be coming to the wii u virtual console
and will require the wiimote to shoot at
the screen unfortunately there are no
plans to reissue the original zapper gun
when you play the system
there was also a lot of mario kart news
revealed today so if you want to see
that head on over to gamespot.com and
for more updates on nintendo in general
go to gamespot.com news